[Música]
bienvenidos a reporteros de france 24
gracias por estar con nosotros
comenzamos
las últimas elecciones regionales en
francia dejaron en evidencia un
abstencionismo récord en el país del más
del 66% muy pocos salieron a votar una
alerta no sólo para los partidos
políticos también para la ciudadanía los
decepcionados de la política en este
país son millones especialmente jóvenes
esa falta de interés en las elecciones
vienen además de la decepción de una
falta de representación en la política
mientras que los medios tradicionales
son acusados de participar en un sistema
democrático fallido este abstencionismo
no se veía desde el referendo del año
2000 en el que se votó por acortar el
mandato presidencial de 7 a 5 años un
equipo de france 24 se reunió con
quienes ya hacen parte de la generación
sin voto para entender el porqué de este
fenómeno esta es la historia
[Música]
en enero de 2021 firmamos la compra de
la casa desde que estoy aquí siento que
estoy viviendo mi mejor vida y que me
siento realizada en mi máximo sueño era
vivir en un colectivo experimentar la
vida campesina
para mí es un acto político decir no a
lo que estaba destinado y me entendés
es decir ser una ingeniera que trabaja
para las multinacionales es un acto
político rechazar un gran salario un
acto político vivir de forma sobria
vivir fuera de las normas es un acto
político
tienen entre 25 y 35 años y comparten el
mismo ideal de vida
victoria y sus amigos desconfían de los
bancos han reunido sus ahorros y han
pedido préstamos a sus familiares para
comprar esta casa en normandía su sueño
de cambio comienza aquí lejos de la
sociedad de consumo que rechazan
suponemos que las plantas se ayudan
mutuamente el copper un poco como las
personas que compran una casa juntas se
intercambian nutrientes y se protegen
mutuamente contra las plagas que llega
desde el estado o el capitalismo
[Risas]
así que hay algunos que son médicos de
la calle por ejemplo que trataran a
otros
las reglas son claras hablar de todo
compartir los gastos y compartir las
comidas
el jardín tenemos toda la lechuga que se
acaba de cosechar todos los días hacemos
una ensalada con verduras del jardín
vamos a disfrutar hablando de política
hoy votamos por el menos peor a veces
siento que nos han robado nuestros
sueños y nuestras vidas así que para mí
tiene sentido recuperar el poder pero no
el poder en el sentido de dominar a los
demás sino el poder de vivir como tierra
en cuanto nos ponemos de acuerdo entre
nosotros en nuestra comunidad hacemos
política entre nosotros y finalmente no
necesitamos poner un nombre detrás no
todos ven el sentido de votar prefieren
reinventar la vida comunitaria a su
propio nivel los ocho miembros
fundadores proceden de diversos ámbitos
algunos de las mejores escuelas de
negocios o de ingeniería como la
politécnica
jonas dejó su tierra en bélgica a menudo
se ríen de nosotros porque no hemos
tenido un gobierno durante mucho tiempo
pero creo que si decidimos delegar lo
todo como presidente o como el de ahora
la gente no se involucrará quizás esto
es lo que muestra la frustración de la
gente que no vota porque no hay
suficiente intercambio discusión a
menudo nos preguntan quién es su jefe el
encargado del jardín el director del
proyecto
no tenemos un líder este es nuestro
imaginario político
[Música]
así que aquí estamos en el espacio de
coworking jonas está trabajando en un
boom sobre el colectivo sobre la
historia de nuestra aventura
no todos los amigos y familias
entendieron esta elección de vivir en
comunidad lo cual puede recordar cierto
movimiento nacido en los años 60
no me gusta mucho el término hippie es
un imaginario un poco desordenado tonto
y soñador
si somos soñadores pero muy organizados
pensamos mucho hablamos mucho somos
limpios limpiamos bien comemos bien
trato de alejarme un poco de estos
clichés
xl
si somos limpios reivindicó el término
hippie y con todos los puntos positivos
cuando se utiliza el término neohippies
tiene mucho sentido aportó cosas no
podemos decir que llegó hasta el final
pero lo recuperamos trabajando en él y
utilizando los códigos que encontramos
bueno
hacer política de forma diferente es
también la elección de tatiana bandos su
campo de acción las redes sociales y
vídeos que reciben cientos de miles de
visitas también se me acusó de haber
cambiado de bando de ser racista y
fascista
originaria de lorena se afilió al
partido de izquierdas de jean luc
mélenchon antes de dar un portazo
-sector que deje la izquierda desde la
izquierda sin arrepentir migra rompí con
la izquierda porque la izquierda dejó de
estar del lado de su gente ha negado sus
valores su historia su clase su país
ella reniego de los suyos es terrible
decirlo pero francia está siendo
destrozada desmantelada en términos de
industria agricultura e incluso cultura
y hay gente sentada en viejas
habitaciones del sol
preguntándose si su ideología es la
mejor y que intentan demostrarlo al
mundo donde rechaza la división
izquierda derecha y considera que los
verdaderos extremistas son los partidos
políticos pro globalización es
su colapso se entiende la abstención
hace unos años que me abstengo o voto en
blanco con ánimos no
y quiero poder votar por algo que
importe algo que todo el mundo vivir una
vida de esta revolucionaria de corazón
ve a los partidos políticos y a los
medios de comunicación como una clase
dominante por lo tanto se dirige
directamente a los usuarios de internet
sin ningún tipo de filtro profesor de
inglés en otra vida creó el feed de
noticias contó ninguna tenemos los
tratados de libre comercio y discursos
que hablan de subir de categoría pero en
realidad para la mayoría de la gente es
más bien lo contrario lo que está
sucediendo
todo lo que hace soñar algo es burgués
citadino para ellos está bien seguro que
tiene el dinero para comprar comida
ecológica
este tubo tan comprometido habla de un
proyecto ciudadano más que militar
consideramos que no somos objetivos no
hay nada malo en llevar un punto de
vista siempre que se asuma como tal que
se someta a la crítica y al debate
democrático cuál es ese punto al que
está bueno depende del tema y el punto
de vista puede evolucionar hemos
revisado nuestra posición en varios
temas como la energía nuclear por
ejemplo donde estábamos bastante
influenciados por el discurso imperante
entonces cuando empiezas a mirar los
números los hechos nos decimos a
nosotros mismos que tal vez estábamos
equivocados si usted aprecia nuestro
trabajo y quiere contribuir a su
financiación le invitamos a hacer clic
en el enlace para tatiana abantos un
rayo de esperanza llegó con los chalecos
amarillos estos ciudadanos que ocuparon
las rotondas para exigir poder
adquisitivo un franco agulo fue uno de
los portavoces del movimiento
[Música]
el día del trabajo el abogado de
gonzález de nuevo a la calle hola somos
de montroi encantado
seguimos su blog y vemos que empezaste a
explicar cómo prepararte a pensar no me
tranquilizo porque me parece muy larga
tu historia nosotros que imaginamos la
revolución a nuestros puertos creo que
el cambio tardará unos años en
producirse
a nivel político crees que no podemos
involucrarnos de ninguna manera no creo
en absoluto desgraciadamente que sea un
candidato antisistema que haría tengamos
cuidado que yo vaya tenga empezado en
eeuu no está bien que las clases
dirigentes de eeuu tengan miedo y tú
eres el que se va a presentar y que no
va a representar no hay ningún partido
político alternativo y no hay ningún
candidato que pueda surgir con esos
medios los medios de comunicación de
invisibilizar andes calificando lo que
tiene así es no me invitan en los medios
de comunicación en qué medios estoy te
invitamos plaza de la república los
chalecos amarillos tratan de encontrarse
dónde estás y ahí estás
cuando esa persona
perdió un ojo durante una de las
manifestaciones en parís john rodríguez
es uno de los símbolos de la lucha de
esta francia de los olvidados el
movimiento de los chalecos amarillos se
ha agotado pero la ira no frente al
problema de votar es que si es dar
nuestro voto por un día en la mañana de
un domingo de la primavera y tener que
callar por cinco años no creo que valga
la pena dar nuestro voto hoy el mundo va
muy rápido no tenemos tiempo de esperar
cinco años para pedir la opinión del
pueblo es importante conocer el sentido
del pueblo por referéndum o por una
democracia directa en fin las formas son
múltiples
entre la desilusión y el fatalismo
muchos no irán a votar
françois bulo los entiende sueña con un
cambio de mentalidad y un nuevo sistema
económico
no consigo aprovecharme de mi poca
comodidad mi estatus y licitación
material
creo que cuando se tiene una educación
superior se tienen los medios para
acceder al conocimiento y los
privilegios que requiere la posición
social para devolverlo al resto de la
sociedad
[Música]
a 50 km de la capital el departamento de
escena y mar con sus pequeñas ciudades y
rotondas
emanuel es ex alcalde los alcaldes y
cargos electos locales vimos a escalar
crisis de los ricos amarillos es decir
que claramente el alcalde es un
barómetro de la sociedad cuyos electores
no eres un político desconectado de todo
puedo decir que fui el primero en
entenderlo me ha elegido a los 29 años
no imaginaba la carga de trabajo poca
gente sabe que cuando hay un momento de
angustia social problemas de corte
familiar se llama inmediatamente al
alcalde lo mismo ocurre con las obras es
el alcalde que gestiona con su equipo de
gobierno cuando se tiene una inquietud
con la comuna o similares es el alcalde
quien está en primera dieron a geacam
puñal ya recibió no presentarse a la
reelección y dedicarse a su familia y a
sus actividades profesionales como
empresario del sector de la seguridad
guarda aún amargos recuerdos
donde vio como la política puede haber y
generar odio
estábamos en el baile el 14 de julio de
2015 había alguien alcoholizado que ni
siquiera era constituyente de mi ciudad
que empezó a insultar a mi policía
municipal entablar el diálogo intentó
estrangular me a puñetazo porque era el
alcalde el representante de la autoridad
local
sólo quería romper mi la carta en 2020
un informe mostró que los insultos y
ataques contra los alcaldes habían
triplicado en un año
el malestar es real lo que llama crisis
de vocaciones entre los cargos electos
de los pequeños el trabajo es exigente
el salario es bajo porque normalmente en
política
porque es un desastre
porque hago política y porque no estoy
en el mismo bando
el ex alcalde se sintió abandonado
mientras el estado exigía cada vez más a
las autoridades locales escribió sobre
su experiencia en un libro ya no será
candidato pero como tantos franceses
continuará siguiendo la política con
interés
algunos lectores que dijeron que a nivel
de medios son iguales
recordemos que ahora en 1945 no tenían
derecho a francia
votar en blanco abstenerse o elegir a
regañadientes millones de franceses
están decepcionados
algunas personas que se han
desilusionado con los partidos quieren
reinventar la acción política tocar la
conciencia de la gente para cambiar el
sistema
[Música]
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
recuerde que puede ingresar a nuestra
página web más 24 punto com para ver
esta y las anteriores emisiones hasta la
próxima semana